hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back
back look this is just an excuse for me
to play god for a few moments and see
what kind of chaos i can cause
the moment that i'm given a modicum of
power if you remember ultimate epic
battle simulator
one did i ever
did i make a video on up ultimate epic
battle sim did i
listen did i make a video on
i think i did thank you but i think i
did i appreciate it i know you went to
the effort of getting that but to be
perfectly honest now i'm rejecting it
because i think i did and i'm going to
believe that i did
thank you for having the proof but i'm
not going to look at it
i don't need to do that with all the
self-confidence i have in myself
wow
hey so this is ultimate epic battle
simulator 2 and what you have in here is
a weight blood volumes like loud blood
like this goddamn loud music can i turn
this music down there we go
thank you
all right
you know what i'm just going to take it
out entirely i don't i don't feel like
it licks you and add your own music
that's what really matters okay armies 2
okay
ancient greek spartan
okay and
[Music]
now
we're getting into it so we've got 10
000 no sorry i apologize 100 000
battle ducks
versus 100 000 free-range chickens
oh my god oh holy crap
that
is
a lot
of battle ducks wow the detail there is
impressive that is a lot of ducks
okay so um hundred thousand battle good
god you're so far away
they must have to do some crazy
optimization to make this work
hi
well yeah i don't know what i was
expecting you are just chickens which is
fine because that's exactly what's gonna
help you win this war okay go
k stands for kill wow
[Music]
oh yeah sorry you're adding in your own
music
[Music]
wow
okay so that's one side
i think you hear the cacophony of the
clucks bouncing off the hills unless you
are actually screaming
[Applause]
[Laughter]
don't make me come over there
[Applause]
[Laughter]
holy crap
that was much funnier than i thought it
would be
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
let me try to i think i can possess one
of them
yeah here we go
i'm going in
[Applause]
i'm dodging i'm bobbing and weaving i'm
bobbing and weaving oh god
i've been hit
i'm stunned
never mind i'm dead i thought the
chickens didn't stand a chance but i
guess i didn't know the powers that they
had inside of them all along
so i'm sorry i'm actually going to call
this one a uh oh wait sorry p mode
[Laughter]
lexington put up some sad music because
this is truly a massacre these brave
ducks
waddling straight into the face of death
no one shall remember their deeds
for history
is written by the victors
lo and behold
the power of the hens
free reigns as they are
oppress the freedoms
of those noble ducks
[Music]
some kind of symbolism about
the wheels of the the gears of the
the
butchery of war i don't know i'm not
good at this rts mode
attack
focus this spot
all right it's it's a massacre
that did very poorly performed
wonderfully in terms of like uh computer
performance that was actually quite good
i i had no problems with that uh but as
far as like a fair fight i don't think
that was very good i have a funny
feeling mantis trip also have a ranged
attack i'm just gonna put them closer
just so that they start fighting sooner
but i also don't think this is going to
go well i thought that battle ducks
would be like the dominant
uh party in the animal category but it
turns out that they are completely
trounced by uh
everything else
hello ago
[Laughter]
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
they're just getting punched into clouds
of feathers oh my i mean i knew that the
mantis rip would probably wall up this
one but man they really truly just
nothing but blood and feathers left over
wham
wow let me possess you
i'm going in
that's all i can do is peck
peck futility
[Applause]
all right well um
yeah it turns out the battle duck they
ain't too good ducks got zero kills that
entire time it was a massacre
action man who the hell is that
oh my god no it's john wick
i'm so sorry
oh
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh my god
[Applause]
well i had a theory and it did not turn
out to be good for the ducks
but you know
chuck norris can't be as bad
uh yeah uh
yeah
kind of going as expected
yeah not a kill not a kill for the ducks
not a single kill for the ducks against
an army of chuck norris
i'm pretty sure that's the plural of
norris's i don't know either way this is
a massacre again okay so clearly there's
like a numeric problem here there's too
many numerals
over on the side opposing the ducks so
what we need is to reduce their numerals
down
so that there's some kind of a chance
for these ducks to survive that would be
the ideal is that they at least have a
chance to score one kill and i think a
ratio of ten to one ducks to nikola
teslas
is at least unless they shoot
oh my god did they shoot lightning oh no
oh
your neck
no
oh no
oh god no
oh
jeez
[Music]
oh my god
go buddies go you can make it oh
[Music]
hey
here my best
friend
[Music]
you
hey buddy how about yourself oh god
[Music]
it's almost beautiful in a way if it
wasn't absolutely horrifying
which it certainly is
hey maybe i'll take a tesla and go for a
few
bam
eh
i'm diving deep into duck territory
you can't get me
i've carved a line right through the
ducks
what i don't have a battle cry like
ghost science or anything like that just
just nothing just shouting
all right i thought that the numbers
could work in the favor of the ducks but
it turns out that it could not you think
that you're going to be a hero if you
even if you are a battle duck but turns
out no american soldier shotgun sherman
german soldier
sure
oh is that like the tank um let me see
what else we got here standards standard
zombie
look how tiny that oh
this will be perfect i think
that the
ducks might have a chance against some
slow zombies there's going to be 10 000
of them
it'll be easy i know that when this game
gets more developed there'll be
obviously more characters but i really
hope they add voice lines to all of them
i think i think it really adds something
okay ah zombos okay this is good
they might have a chance because they
still got to go melee and so long as
they have to do melee there might be an
opportunity to overwhelm the zombies
that's a lot of blood
oh but one down
get it pal look at that look at the
damage to the ankles
oh that's kind of a lot of blood
wow
[Music]
this is glorious
it is quite fantastical
[Music]
yes
fight
it's kind of close actually
i wonder if i can get them surrounded
ooh rts mode and then i grab you guys
and i tell you to go this way and flank
them
yeah you flank them over there and then
i
will grab all of you guys
and you're going to flank them here
you're going to cut them around to the
back you're going to cut them off at the
pass there you go now we're getting
strategy here yes
look at them they have to peel off from
the back to try to counteract the the
the the flanking maneuver but they're
not going to be able to get it because
they're not going to be able to get
enough there's too many the overwhelming
number going towards the back is gonna
be too much thin out the front lines
try to try to use your numbers to
overwhelm circle and and crush them yeah
yeah draw them out draw them out yeah
yeah
there we go
[Applause]
yeah get him yeah
yeah get him
hell yeah
they can't do much when they're all
isolated now you got a big old duck
problem behind you what are you gonna do
about that pal whoa what does oh my god
he's a hero oh he's dead but he was a
hero i don't even know how you got back
there
it's still close that's the problem it's
still kind of a close fight
because if you look at the ratios it's
almost it's very close there's a lot of
blood on the ground but i'm thinking
that as
the zombies start to lose their numbers
in greater and greater droves it's gonna
lead the ducks to be able to overwhelm
and isolate them and they're not gonna
have their numbers
uh but at the same time that number is
kinda going up
they got like a roaming squads of
zombies around the back i'm not i'm not
even sure how they're managing to do
that oh hello
this document actually is here
interesting what are you guys doing over
there
why aren't you fighting
go fight damn it
fight like your life depends on it which
it do
oh they're about to get a break in the
line here
yes
yes
yes
i think the tide might almost be turning
let me get some action on the ground
here
oh god no no no
[Applause]
don't let yourselves get overwhelmed
brothers
pick off the weak ones
peck
peck like your life depends on it
wichita oh i'm dead
i'm alive
all right
oh actually
the numbers don't look nearly as good as
they once did because all of these ducks
are just being lazy [ __ ]
go
also did i mention i'm not very good at
rts so i don't even know if i'm doing
the right strategy about that which i'm
probably not hey if you're watching the
video to this point in the video now is
your chance to tell me exactly all the
ways that i did wrong write detailed
comments
i'll be
i'll be picking the winner based on how
hard my feelings are hurt
how bad you make me think
how much you make me realize how bad i
am at rts and also speaking oh
oh i don't know i don't know i don't
know if the ducks are gonna prevail i
think i wasn't using my numbers
appropriately i think i kept sending him
around for the pincer move but i
underestimated the ability for the
zombies just to create a wall of flesh
but that being said these guys are about
to cave in oh but the numbers are
getting worse a lot worse for the ducks
here they just can't make the difference
at the front lines
oh but you got the flanking ducks you
got the flanking what are they doing
what they what are they doing why are
they just sitting there why would you
just no go further go further go further
ducks go further ducks yeah yeah yeah
this is where we this is where we uh
hold them this is where we fight
this is where they die oh looks like
they're doing their own flanking
maneuver on us
look at all the inroads that ducks must
have made in here like the trails of
zombies just like you can see them like
fingers spreading around little rivers
of corpses this one didn't do so good
but these actually made some good
inroads
all right i think i've got all of them
kill you this one
and then kill this one i'm micromanaging
kill
if i get my clicks per minute up it'll
definitely work out in my favor and more
zombies will die
oh look a skull's opening up here
oh no
oh no
oh no my dudes
no
no
oh no the western flank is falling
[Applause]
oh but maybe not also there seems to be
a breach
rush the breach
rush the bridge the bridge what are you
guys doing over there the breach the
breach breach it
there's a hole breach push the breach oh
i think they stopped because
the the thing i targeted didn't hurt
died
they just called it an end there
oh the western front might actually pull
through on this but there's still so
many zombies over there
oh no it's not good guys it's not good
it's not good guys no
no
[Applause]
can i get a uh
[Music]
can i get f's in the comments for these
brave ducks
i thought that i had given them a
match-up that they could succeed on but
alas
me as a general is not meant to lead
ducks
i was not able to take advantage of
their
complete skill set i take full
responsibility for this failure and i
tender my
resignation as duck general effective
immediately
they were brave
they were so brave
they fought valiantly
for a cause that they believed in
[Applause]
to protect the world from
the zombie if infestation
they did everything that they could
and
were for the most part completely
without leadership even now
this duck's just standing aimlessly
awaiting orders but unable to do
anything without my direct command
in fact they said
that i gave far too many speeches
and not enough orders
for them to know how to fight
effectively
and that i was so wrapped up in my own
self-image my narcissism oozing out of
every core of my body
that i was not able to see the blood
oozing out of every pore
of their feathery body it is my fault
yes
for who else could have taken the mantle
of responsibility such as i
whose strong arms could have held their
lives all in my hands and wasted them
but i i should be given an award for the
horrendous guilt i feel inside my soul
for how negligent i was as a leader
i probably am the most negligent that
ever lived i probably feel the most
guilt of anyone
ever
it's all my fault
all me
anyway um this is sad let's assume that
some of these guys ran away and uh
didn't die that's what i'm gonna that's
what i'm gonna assume i'm actually gonna
reduce the number down because these do
take quite a while okay standard zombie
was the only evil thing medieval yeah
footmen archer catapult
those don't sound too good
redcoat
fantasy troll
troll troll
what if there's only a hundred trolls
trolls sound like they might be big and
strong so this could probably be a
better a better fight
ah
those are kind of big but it's a hundred
versus 10 000. go my ducky brethren go
oh
oh
oh
is that your blood or their blood whose
blood are you covered with are you about
to die or
or are you just covered in duck blood
i'm not seeing any trolls falling
i'm seeing a lot of ducks exploding in
zero that i'm i've now come to the
conclusion that these are in fact not
the troll's blood it is in fact the um
the duck blood that has exploded all
over them because of the sheer force
with which they are impacting these
ducky bodies and they simply uh combust
into feathers
oh
yeah well you're doing okay yeah keep
pecking there buddy
i really thought that they got kind of
like a lot of bloody right when they
were about to die but um like those ones
they're really bloody boy that probably
just means that they killed like a lot
of
ducks
like you how many oh you have twelve
thousand
ah
you're nowhere near about to
ah
oh
oh
no
[Music]
that was my bed but some
how these ducks will know
true
victory archer full auto well that's not
good and i didn't even pick archer
fulato i picked sherman full auto i
don't even know what a full auto tank
would be
ducks i'm sorry i was more curious than
actually concerned about your victory
here
all right
that did not go well okay is there any
single one of these roman soldier let's
put a thousand roman soldiers versus ten
thousand battle ducks okay
okay
okay this seems reasonable
go get a battle ducks
[Applause]
ah
okay they're not dying immediately which
is good
um
the roman soldiers are kind of
oh
[Music]
i really do seem to have it out for
these ducks but the truth is i really
don't
i i want them to succeed i want to see
them
be victorious i know that they have
suffered defeat after defeat but i keep
thinking that i'm going to give them a
fight that they can win but apparently i
can't i'm incapable of it and i don't
want it to just be completely one-sided
i don't want to just be like oh you're
going to be 10 000 versus one enemy like
i wanna give them a fight that they can
be proud of something that they can
go home to their duck families and and
i don't know
eat dinner or something
talk about it over a beer a duck beer
a de beer
i'm just getting stabbed by a bunch of
romans
that's no way to go for a duck
or maybe it's a great way to go for a
duck i don't know i don't know what
ducks like but i know that they like to
win
and so i'm gonna give him that sweet dub
maybe spartan persian um
okay so if this is set up like 300 then
it was like the spartans versus the
persians it was like if you wanted to do
a 300 versus like 10 000 or so i'm
imagining the persians are probably the
weaker unit of the two so let's build
this like the battle of thermopylae was
that what it was called and let's put
these ducks in this valley
and then bring these
persian soldiers over here to claim it
ah
okay let me actually make them 0.5 so
they're long right so these ducks now
fit in this valley
that they are defending because they've
got a choke hold on this
and i think that
given the dimensions of the area
they should win actually wait no i'm
doing this opposite i'm thinking about
that completely wrong
okay go for it
[Applause]
okay
um so far bad so far very whoa maybe not
maybe so far okay
so far okay
interesting okay
so wow
what
wait
what is happening to the mountain behind
me is it melting is it melting
oh
it's deleting geometry as i'm looking
but that's fine
it's duck jesus smiling down on all
these ducks
look at them
okay they might actually stand a chance
[Applause]
this might actually work
this might work they might win even
though i set this completely not what
the battle of thermopylae or even
whatever the hell that was was
i didn't do this right but it doesn't
matter because i think they're going to
win
unbelievably
i think that somehow they're going to
win is that oh that's a river of blood
flowing down this hill
ah
ah
it really is a river of blood
that's kind of cool
look at that
they got a blood river and we're kind of
getting a blood lake
[Applause]
that's horrifying
good god
[Music]
[Applause]
my brave ducks
my brave brave ducks
you used the landscape not to your
advantage but my god you used it
you were here on the land
you fought back
you triumphed
you flanked them
you broke their spirit
and you won the battle
i'm proud of you ducks
i am so proud
look at that
wow
now i just want to know how big of a
blood river i can make okay a mountain
of ducks versus a uh a ten tank
battalion of full auto shermans
my god this is probably gonna crash the
computer oh my god they're falling
they're full they're tumbling down the
mountain
does it have a million ducks in here
well we're about to find out go
oh 500 000 it looks like i think they're
falling down the mountain and dying yeah
oops
ah
my bad my bad guys my bad i don't know
how close they need to be to be in range
of the shermans but uh it shall be a
glorious charge nonetheless
my god they are not gonna get down that
mountain are they oh
i neglected to realize that there would
be no blood if the blood is vaporized in
a barrage of uh
tank fire
let me rethink this one
what if instead okay
i'm gonna make a custom character we're
gonna do
spartan okay wow nice man we're gonna do
spartans we're gonna make him nigh
unkillable
we're gonna make him do unbelievable
damage
we're gonna make him attack real fast
we're gonna make him attack
no no that's good impact force uh zero
splash damage
yep
nah they don't need splash damage ah
they need nah they don't need splash
damage they'll be fine
uh
leonidas we got a leonidas here
and instead of this being here we're
going to switch these around because
they're going to be coming in
and you guys are going to be holding
just a team of 300
double wide maybe even triple wide right
here at the highest part of the hill and
then we're just gonna see how much blood
is gonna come gushing down this hill and
to see if it forms like a lake or
something i don't know we'll see
[Applause]
i will die with honor
okay well they're ready and they're
getting all hype but here come the ducks
some of them are just oh so eager
[Applause]
who wants to get ducked
god i love the lines that's probably the
best part of any of these games i mean i
don't even know if the other games kind
of had these lines it is beautiful the
first kill
[Music]
oh wow they are kind of slow on the
thrusts did i do that i might have done
that i might have messed up leonidas
ability wow never mind he was way too
fast
okay never mind they are much faster
than i thought they were oh
okay well i'm not seeing a lot of blood
do ducks not have blood
i'm beginning to think that ducks don't
have blood
wow that's a lot of dark
holy crap
[Applause]
i gotta just keep going
oh oh oh
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god
okay well uh
doesn't matter anyway because it turns
out ducks don't have blood let's do uh
spartans to make it um
not fair what's the opposite of fair uh
make them feel bad about themselves and
just how inadequate they really are go
oh wow
it's so shiny look at it so pretty oh my
god it's so pretty
it's so pretty
you didn't tell me that they'd be so
pretty
look at that so pretty
it's like oscillating waves of
gold
shimmering fish scales of glorious
bright light
that's so pretty
why is that so pretty i mean it's about
to turn into a river of blood but it's
very pretty very pretty up and here
comes the blood okay
oh wow yeah that that's oh that's
gushing
oh that's gushing
these guys are just a little twitchy i
think oh my god let's see if i can catch
him in slow motion oh yeah this is slow
motion yeah yeah
yeah
this is what it means to be inferior
gentlemen i apologize uh
you should um
should have trained harder oh my god
there's just a very dense puddle of
blood right here at the bottom it's
supposed to flow down but i don't think
it has enough time to flow down
oh my god you're gonna be oh my god
they're knee-deep in blood well this is
what i wanted i'm gonna let this run for
a while not joking i'm gonna let this
run for a while but i'm gonna park it in
a spot where you can see the trail of
blood kind of develop i think you can
just barely see it here so i'll be back
as this progresses
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
i didn't quite expect that okay god
powers numkeys or mouse wheel to switch
shotgun smite
oh
[Applause]
okay noah's flood i don't know what
noah's flood is gonna be
ah that's what knows maybe we can wash
away some of this whoa they have water
physics in this game
what i'm gonna wash away some of that
blood or maybe it's just gonna mix with
it and it's
it's gonna all turn red
no it cleaned it
kinda
are you guys gonna drown if i do this
whoa
oh i think they took the um city
[Laughter]
that ain't right
i don't think that's right
oh boy well here we go
well i can't really tell if it's doing
anything oh no it's doing something this
guy's drowning
really did give a biblical flood here so
let's um
let's see what more we can do about it
this is cool they got a lot of really
cool stuff going on in this game like a
lot of optimization clearly to get this
much stuff going on at the same time but
i don't know why it's just very very
cool reminds me of like one uh this
specifically reminds me of like um one
of the earliest let's plays i'd i ever
did kind of like after amnesia the dark
descent i wanted to do a different let's
play that wasn't horror based because i
wanted to branch out and i didn't just
want to do horror but i can't remember
what the game was called you were like a
uh a god type person
thing that was guiding
your people trying to get away and you
you were able to be able to ate sand and
like you there was a lot of water
physics involved in the game i don't
remember what the game was called but it
is one of my early early early early
let's plays
wow that is still oh that is that is a
blood tsunami
right well uh that kind of clear oh that
did clear
oh
oh my god
okay well this is horrifying
and yet they still
i don't know if like the floor got dug
down because they were fighting because
i don't remember them they're fighting
on a hill of bodies they're fighting on
the mountain of bodies ah that is
something
that is something else wow okay
wow
and there's the runoff
gross
so
this has been ultimate epic battle
simulator 2. it's a lot improved from
the first one if i
if i'm any judge and i definitely
probably did make a video about the
first one so a lot of cool stuff here
this is a very early release i think
it's like
0.01 or something like that 0.11 or
something like that it was on the main
menu so look forward to seeing more out
of this i think the voice lines is fun i
think the powers is fun i think a lot of
the what they have is going on is fun
like i don't know how much charm you can
get out of
just making little computer things fight
each other
endlessly but uh they've done a lot i am
very impressed so yeah link is in the
description if you want to play first
your elf
link is in the description if you want
to play this for yourself also is my
video the first time i played it that
definitely exists if it does exist it is
in the description or if it's not in the
description it's definitely in my
channel somewhere so you got to dig down
and find it yeah but i think that this
qualifies as a sport of some kind tyler
would be able to approve that because he
does have a master's degree in sports
administration and in fact uh i talk
about sports with tyler a lot on our
podcast go my favorite sports team which
is where i a man who does not know
anything about sports talks to a guy who
does know a lot about sports so even if
you don't like sports you can listen to
the podcast enjoy me and tyler hanging
out he would love that so uh go check it
out that link is also in the description
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
bye